o la regresamos con un nuevo avance
informativo en francés 24 en plena
crisis social política y también
económica y a tan solo dos semanas de la
explosión en el puerto de beirut líbano
conoce hoy el tan esperado veredicto en
el juicio por el asesinato del ex primer
ministro del país
rafic hariri y otras 21 personas
perpetrado en el año 2005 según la
justicia no hay evidencia de que el
liderazgo de hezbollah o desidia
estuvieran implicados el tribunal
especial para el líbano aseguró este
martes que no recibió ninguna prueba de
la participación directa del gobierno
sirio o de algún dirigente del grupo
chiíta libanés hezbollah en el atentado
terrorista que se cobró la vida del ex
primer ministro libanés no obstante los
jueces consideraron probados los cargos
contra un presunto integrante de
hezbollah en la preparación de este
ataque y los otros tres acusados fueron
absueltos
el tribunal ha fallado y en nombre de la
familia del difunto primer ministro
rafic hariri y en nombre de las familias
de los mártires y las víctimas aceptamos
el fallo del tribunal y más temprano
nuestra corresponsal en beirute el
botnet nos reportará detalles acerca de
cómo ha sido recibido este veredicto por
los libaneses y en particular cómo fue
recibido por familiares del fallecido
primer ministro esto nos decía
la verdad es que tanto baje a hariri que
es la hija mayor del ministro asesinado
al igual que su hijo saad los dos han
aceptado el veredicto porque en cierta
manera aunque como hemos dicho antes
hayan sido los individuos y no el grupo
los que han sido juzgados en cierta
manera lo que demuestra que hezbollah yo
no tiene impunidad ante la justicia
muchos libaneses sí que están esperando
que esta noche podría haber algún tipo
de rifirrafes entre los dos grupos ya
que se trata de un jazz y chiíes que
durante la guerra civil lucharon los
unos contra los otros vamos ahora eeuu
porque el partido demócrata comenzó su
convención para designar a joe biden
como su candidato para las elecciones
presidenciales y esto por supuesto con
el objetivo de vencer al presidente de
donald trump el cónclave del partido
estuvo marcado en gran parte por las
críticas al mandatario y debido a la
pandemia de kobe 19 esta convención ha
sido totalmente virtual y tuvo un
carácter mucho más político que otros
años
de los discursos más encendidos fue el
de la ex primera dama michelle obama
quien entre otras cosas afirmó que
donald trump es el presidente equivocado
para el país y malí vive por estas horas
momentos de incertidumbre y de alarma y
es que un grupo no identificado de
hombres de las fuerzas armadas
protagonizaron un motín en una base
militar ubicada a 15 kilómetros de la
capital del país y han trascendido a
versiones sobre un posible golpe de
estado aunque de momento no está
confirmado oficialmente en la capital
bamako reina la confusión y la mayoría
de oficinas del gobierno bancos y
comercios han cerrado sus puertas en
medio de rumores no confirmados todavía
de que los militares amotinados habrían
detenido a algunos ministros del actual
gobierno de excepción formado el pasado
27 de julio y también a otros altos
cargos pero ninguna fuente oficial lo ha
confirmado hasta el momento
continuaba la atención en belarús tras
los comicios presidenciales tildados
como fraudulentos por la oposición en
los que el presidente alexander
lukashenko fue reelecto ahora el
mandatario acusa a los opositores de
querer usurpar el poder tras jornadas de
masivas manifestaciones opositoras
exigiendo la renuncia del presidente
lukashenko acusó al consejo coordinador
opositor que celebró el martes su
primera reunión de intentar tomar el
poder para el mandatario la oposición
busca que le cedan el mando del país y
calificó a esta maniobra como un intento
de hacerse con el gobierno
muchas gracias por acompañarnos
regresamos en breve con más noticias
quédense con nosotros hay mucho más en
france 24 y en france 24 punto com